so this is making the rounds right now
john oliver's video on coal right off
the bat let me say something
i think john oliver's funny i think he's
much i think samantha b
is about as funny as swimming through a
pool of age-riddled needles
actually that's kind of funny okay but i
do think john oliver can be
funny jared's doing it unlike samantha b
he does make a genuine attempt to source
some of his claims however people pass
it along
often because they think it's
authoritative on the subject and has an
english accent so he sounds intelligent
a lot of it's better than using salon
sure
or or uh uh daily beast is the only
sources that samantha b does but a lot
of his claims are simply factually
inaccurate and in this case with the
coal
video which is going viral uh they're
very
misleading if they're not completely
inaccurate so he makes a few it's a 20
minute video but we want to go through
the top five claims made in his coal
segment
that are incorrect let's go to his first
claim since the last fourth quarter of
last year to
most recently added almost 50 000 jobs
in the coal sector in the month of may
alone almost 7 000 jobs
okay so the only problem there is that
those numbers are [ __ ]
the bureau of labor statistics says the
actual number of coal jobs created since
last year has been just
1300 so that 50 000 new jobs claim was
off
by 48 700. okay so we'll get to
his first claim here is that the jobs
claim was way off we'll get to the jobs
created and why that's incorrect
i think that's down the list at number
four but right off the bat we need to
put this
in context obama killed 83 000 coal jobs
and he shut down 400 mines during his
presidency
barack obama flagrantly bragged that he
would shut down the coal business this
is important to note
you can talk about the jobs claims but
this is based on the idea that donald
trump is going to bring back jobs that
were shut off by barack obama so that's
the premise
he needs to refute that premise because
that is based on the
undeniable fact of jobs lost and of
course barack obama's rhetoric
which you can look up for yourself let's
go to his second claim where he says
that coal jobs
and he tries to move on through this so
he doesn't substantiate it but it's
still
just as important that it's coal jobs
are catastrophic for the environment
trump claims coal is a huge priority for
his white house and let's set aside
tonight
the fact that it is environmentally
catastrophic which we shouldn't
because it is based on what
based on what the simple idea that what
coal emits more
more co2 it's dirtier listen germany has
completely moved to green energy
and their co2 emissions have gone up not
down we've talked about that
yeah okay we've reduced our co2
emissions significantly in the united
states
so based on the idea that it emits more
well we don't necessarily see that and
okay what's the alternative what's the
alternative to using our own
resources clean coal or fracking which
you oppose or offshore drilling which
you oppose all of which are opposed by
john oliver
and barack obama all of them what's the
alternative
being dependent on foreign energy places
like saudi arabia
all throughout the middle east or asia
where they have no environmental
standards whatsoever
so here he says it's catastrophic for
the environment
based on what prove it and then what is
the alternative
this is the real world let's go to his
third claim where he says that coal
mining was already on the decline
despite obama's laws not entirely
inaccurate
but context while coal mining jobs
undoubtedly did decline under obama
it's worth noting that coal mining jobs
have also been declining for decades
okay so you know you've heard that term
there are lies damn lies and statistics
yes but i am a fan of statistics a lot
of people use that to say i don't beli i
don't believe in any
facts because those are damn lies and
that's fake news that's not what we're
saying here
okay but you can take if you take a
graph
and you expand the timeline or shrink it
you can take that you can take it with
the stock market you know gold has done
this right gold has never been worth
nothing neither is diet coke but if you
came in at a certain point
and you sold at a certain point you done
got screwed up that gold was a safe
hedge
should have gone with silver so um
that's what's important here now
he's right if you look since the 1920s
coal was
on the decline it's consistently been on
decline because there are more forms of
energy than ever before but here's
what's important
for the first time in decades right
before barack obama came into office
there was a significant rise in the coal
industry due
to clean coal technology cleaner coal
technology which was championed by the
way by barack obama himself
before he became president he was
borderline a spokesperson
for clean coal technology and using it
here at home until of course he was
against them when he became president of
the united states
so let's move on to number four because
it's integrally tied to claim number
number three that coal jobs went away
because of wind and solar which is the
energy of the
don't laugh let's go don't straw me let
him make the claim
same number go away there is perhaps no
more dramatic evidence
of coal losing out to solar energy than
this
work has begun to power the kentucky
coal mining museum
not by coal but by the sun okay i get it
i understand that's funny a cold museum
being powered by solar energy
no one's against houses up and down
you know the next block having solar
panels having generators or
nearly every rv now has some form of
solar panels yeah as i saw yesterday
ikea has solar panels
okay but solar and wind have failed on a
massive scale you don't have the ability
with countries or with cities
to put it into a generator and
consistently generate power we've talked
about this with our our sven computer
our intern from germany it's failed
unbelievably in germany they have power
droughts and then they have power
surpluses where they sell their energy
at a net negative level here's something
else
solar in wind these green alternative
energies unlike coal can only survive
on massive government subsidies solar
alone has gotten more than 10 times the
subsidies of all
other energy forms combined okay and
just like student loans
what this does what these subsidies do
is they actually increase the cost of
energy
as you see with solar and wind where
their costs when compared with
unsubsidized politically incorrect forms
of energy like nuclear like clean coal
like natural gas they can cost two three
four five
ten times more so this is important to
note
unsubsidized coal was growing completely
subsidized solar and wind has been
failing miserably let's go to claim
number five that donald trump
can't bring back because this is what it
has to tie into for them of course let's
use all this to bash trump
donald trump can't bring back any of
these jobs at all due to automation not
entirely false but let's go
and the hard truth is even if
consumption wasn't declining companies
would still be
cutting jobs as they are increasingly
replacing miners with machines
well that's exactly true that's actually
true some of them now we've talked about
this on this show
in many industries jobs are going away
due to automation now don't do that to
john oliver who's mr fight for 15 we
can't automate
the burger flipping paddy machines
because people need jobs
now all of a sudden he's all about
automation when it comes to targeting
trump for political motivation
so listen it is true um that we can't
bring back
all of the jobs you can't do that in any
industry as technology evolves
however in the coal industry thank god
we have these statistics due to
how severe barack obama's stifling of
the entire industry was
we are seeing a significant amount of
jobs come back fortune now predicts that
in addition to the jobs already created
coal jobs are on the rise this year with
as many as 33
000 employees and contractors regaining
their work who were laid off between
2014 and 2016.
that is huge okay it's not the 83 000
that were directly cut by barack obama
but here's the context that matters
john oliver says no coal is bad for the
environment with no proof
and as you see the graph was going down
so it didn't have anything to do with
barack obama and donald trump can't
bring back
any of these jobs well those aren't true
but let me
paint you a picture and then a potential
parallel universe okay
so here's cole all right cole barack
obama becomes president
proudly says i'll put you out of
business okay so
coal industry you cannot open any more
mines as a matter of fact we're going to
stifle you with such suffocating
legislation
you are going to close 400 minds we are
going to get 83
000 people laid off you can't open any
new mines we're going to hit you with
new taxes new regulations that make it
very very difficult by the way
solar wind green energy we are going to
subsidize you entirely
anything you want doesn't even matter if
you can't turn a dollar doesn't even
matter if you have no intention of
running a business solyndra
we will subsidize you to the tune of
hundreds of billions of dollars
coal green wins solar let's compete
okay now a parallel universe president
coal is already on the increase because
of new technology in coal and we have a
government that says
wow this is great kind of like fracking
we now have a cleaner way to go about
mining coal our own natural resources we
don't need to be dependent on foreign
resources okay
we're going to allow you as long as you
stay within the market regulations and
of course keep your workers safe and
keep your environmental impact to a
minimum
we're going to actually allow you to do
coal that's fine we're not going to shut
anything down you operate on an honest
profit margin by the way wind and solar
you figure it out we're not giving you
any more of our money both of you figure
it out let's see who can operate an
honest profit margin and create the best
form of most efficient energy compete
that changes the graph let me give you
an example let's say the government
comes in today and says louder with
crowder okay listen
we're going a lot to allow you to exist
all right but
you can't create any new mugs you can't
sell any you can generate
no new mug clubs you can keep most of
your subscribers matter of fact we're
going to shut down
uh 4 000 of them we're going to shut
down 4 000 of those accounts
we're not going to help you as a matter
of fact you can't make any new hires
we're going to make sure that you have
to fire
people you can still exist but you have
to follow these regulations but bill
o'reilly god love him who's starting his
own online network
we're going to give you 10 billion
louder with crowder bill o'reilly
compete
see how that works and this is why when
people like john oliver look at this and
they look they're talking about people's
jobs it may not mean a whole lot to you
but 83
000 jobs was a lot to the people who
were in the coal industry certainly the
33 000 people who could gain their jobs
back
and when you see a john oliver who uns
completely unsubstantiated makes claims
of course sets out with a premise and
smugly makes claims about the coal
industry and how this is
how it's going to have to go doesn't
matter if you don't like it this is
where technology is going this is the
future and the government is going to
subsidize it and you just have to get on
board
because there are people like me there
are people like you can you see why
people think of you as an elitist as a
pompous prick as an establishment type
especially when you
oh my friend don oliver use the donald
trump loopholes to buy your 10 million
dollar mansion
i don't know what hey if you like this
video subscribe by clicking the letters
that spell out subscribe also youtube
somewhere in this box has a recommended
video for you
now i don't know what they recommend but
my guess is if you're here it's going to
be something twisted and something you
don't want your parents to see
if you want to see the entire show from
which this clip is taken click one of
the boxes playing next to me that is the
full episode or join the mug club for
the daily show the reason the daily show
isn't on youtube
is because um well youtube doesn't like
some of the things we say